everyone worries about the future now
and then even members of the o5 council
the most powerful figures in the scp
foundation civilians resort to keeping
themselves in blissful ignorance or
relying on the calming platitudes of
horoscopes and fortune cookies but the
o5 council has access to considerably
more accurate methods of understanding
the future that's why when 05-2 began to
feel anxious about the future of the
human race she took matters into her own
hands she'd already spent time using
scp-2003
a device created by the foundation to
travel briefly into the future in hopes
of seeing what fate had in store for
humanity but very few of the futures
shown by
scp-2003 were good ones for the human
race with many showing various
end-of-the-world scenarios playing out
so instead 05-2 decided to make her way
into existential isolation facility beta
an experimental facility that contains
an entirely separate reality in order to
get into contact with scp-411
scp-411 is a centuries-old man from the
future who ages in reverse though his
advanced age has rendered him somewhat
senile useful facts about the future can
sometimes be noted from his scattered
memories of what is yet to come while
getting him to part with this
information is a risky procedure given
that 411 is so old that even extended
conversations might kill him in times of
absolute emergency it's sometimes the
clearest look into the future the
foundation has oh 5-2 hoped that in
talking to scp-411 she could settle some
of her anxieties regarding humanity's
future but the answers she got from the
senile bed-bound ancient precognitive
weren't exactly what she was hoping for
when she asked him whether there was a
future for humanity on earth he
responded the planet of hand this is
what we are to speak of i am from there
you know as are you child you shall know
more of it in thai
i'm glad to be here now instead
greetings prodigal daughter unlike me
you'll be home soon unsatisfied 05-2
left shortly after her anxiety
undeterred little did she know she had
very good reasons to be anxious about
humanity's future and we're not just
talking about nuclear war or climate
change we're talking about the threat
nobody expects scp-001
and this time it isn't the black moon or
the scarlet king or the terrifying when
day breaks today we're talking about
well we'll get to that in due time it'd
be a terrible shame to spoil the
surprise and besides there's a lot of
chaos and horror to get through before
then the foundation has always been
vaguely aware of scp-001 and the
terrible threat it poses towards all of
humanity but that doesn't necessarily
mean they understand its true nature
still does it matter whether or not a
deer understands the hunter's rifle no
only that it must avoid being found
between its crosshairs and the
foundation's method for staying out of
zero zero one's crosshairs was known as
scp-2798 this thaumial class anomaly was
created by the foundation to
specifically keep zero zero one away
from all of us since the start of
recorded history strange anomalous
activity has been reported causing
suffering and distress against humans
this eventually led to the creation of
the scp foundation which seemingly
correlated with a massive spike in
severe and dangerous anomalous activity
all of this activity was believed to
lead back to
scp-001 an anomalous hostile and highly
intelligent entity or series of entities
that wish to do humanity great harm
rather than playing whack-a-mole with
zero zero one's anomalies they hoped to
deal with its threat more directly
leading to the creation of
scp-2798 to go into too much detail
would probably derail the video entirely
but for us to give you a brief summary
of what exactly scp-2790
is it's comprised of 8 000 melted human
souls as well as several scps being
pumped down into the earth's mantle
while this came with certain unpleasant
side effects it also acted as a kind of
cloaking device by pumping so much life
essence into the earth it made us all
seem like one single organism thus
keeping the watchful eyes of scp-001
away from all of us this initiative was
given the code name project serapis
here's the problem though project's
therapist was never meant to be a
permanent fix and what's more it's
actually been degrading over the last
several decades until it finally
recently collapsed earth's cloaking
device had collapsed with it and now the
eyes of scp-001 were starting to come
into focus on our pale blue dot and just
like o5-2 had feared things were about
to get an awful lot worse on november
2nd 2016
001 detected the population of earth and
began to work its terrifying magic it
began creating what is known as altered
phenomenon out of pre-existing anomalies
think of them almost as super scps
almost universally stronger and more
dangerous than their original
incarnations if you thought the scps
were dangerous before then these new
ones are your worst nightmare it didn't
take long for chaos to break out a huge
number of the foundation databases
across the globe experienced sudden
collapses the horrifying monster that
scp-058 the heart of darkness belonged
to began attacking its containment area
massive containment breaches occurred in
a huge number of sites and soldiers and
containment experts were dispatched in
hopes of bringing this rapidly
escalating situation back under control
photos of scp-439 the bone hive earwigs
were somehow leaked on imgur some
constellations even began disappearing
all over the sky
scp-1000s launched a violent coup and
took over blah luck oregon the global
zero zero one situations escalated and
anomalies began overwhelming different
foundation strongholds some sites were
considered lost though employees were
threatened with termination if they
abandoned their posts some anomalies
went entirely missing into the civilian
world and started causing chaos amal
hamzi one of the foundation's interfaith
liaisons from armed area 19 was quoted
saying the day will come when this earth
will be substituted with a new earth and
also the heavens and everyone will be
brought before god the one the supreme
allah preserve us you're probably
wondering given that an army of enhanced
scps were released to cause violence and
chaos across the globe by scp-001
do we have any specific examples of some
of the anomalies made bigger badder and
a hell of a lot more dangerous by this
mysterious foe don't worry the rest of
this video is going to be specific
examples of exactly that take for
example
scp-087 the endless stairwell this went
from a localized entity at an
undisclosed university administrative
building to an even more dangerous
stairwell in the pentagon which had the
ability to open and close its doorway at
will presumably hoping to capture some
power players from the united states
department of defense the terrifying
scp-106 also known as the old man also
got a significant power boost he became
so intelligent that he was capable of
conversing with foundation staff
presumably just to say nasty things to
them as they tortured them to death he
was also able to better control his
dimensional portal abilities making
escape far easier which is bad news for
the human race given the old man's dark
tendencies
scp-294 the coffee machine got an
incredibly weird upgrade now rather than
dispensing items that can mess with
individuals it messes with a global
economy via the success or failure of
the coca-cola company one of the largest
beverage companies in the world
transactions performed on scp-294 will
affect the global stock price and
trading success for the company creating
wild economic instability
scp-662 the butler's handbell that
summons the delightfully practical
butler mr deeds went from convenient to
terrifying any time it was wrung the
ringer was brought to a random unknown
location where they would be asked to
perform a seemingly impossible task and
then be anomalously compelled to
complete said task this could lead to
debilitating and distressing injuries
now you know how poor mr deeds feels
scp-701 the hanged king's tragedy was
originally a lethal cursed play that
causes madness and death for anyone
unlucky enough to witness it after
scp-001 the hanged king's tragedy was
transformed into a mass-marketed hbo
series starring javier bardem in the
title role the show was immediately
renewed for five seasons meaning it will
likely cause horrifying death and
madness for millions across the globe
although given hbo's track record the
last season is likely going to be
terrible
scp-993 was a disturbing anomalous
children's program hosted by the
infamous bobble the clown who would
convince the children in the audience to
commit violent or depraved acts thanks
to the scp-001 boost bobble instead took
up an adult news show on cable
television where he instead exerted his
violent influence over global power
players his guests have included then
united kingdom foreign secretary boris
johnson philippine president rodrigo
duerte canadian prime minister justin
trudeau and national people's congress
of china chairman zhang do zhang
scp-1981 also known as ronald reagan cut
up while talking was a cursed vhs tape
of a ronald reagan speech that shows the
former president being mutilated and
speaking violent nonsense naturally
thanks to scp-001 this obscure little
tape got a serious upgrade it became a
series of massively viewed videos on the
video sharing platform dailymotion it
shows a completely skinned version of
ronald reagan addressing the 2013
meeting of the world economic forum in
davos switzerland rather than the
typical blood and brimstone though the
content of each speech consists of
technical specifications for as yet
unknown anomalous technological devices
scp-2006
also known as too spooky was a
shape-shifter with the stated intention
of causing fear and horror in its
subjects but it thankfully wasn't very
good at this as the foundation tricked
it into occupying the forms of stupid
b-movie monsters however after the
scp-001 upgrade it shifted its goals to
causing happiness and contentment in
order to do this it took the form of
scp-999
but without any of its anomalous effects
instead it absorbed 15 agents saying
this is the closest anyone will be to
achieving happiness as they suffocated
within its inescapable gelatinous mass
scp-2337 also known as dr spanko was a
sentient and sapient male corn cake who
speaks bizarre nonsensical sentences at
an incredibly loud volume destroying
things with the sheer sound of its voice
however thanks to the extra power imbued
by scp-001
dr spenco entered the dream realm he
appeared to people in their dreams all
over the world causing considerable
distress to his victims by speaking to
them in his trademark deafening voice
this has caused general anxiety and
sleep deprivation to rise across the
human population
scp-2845 also known as the deer was
terrifyingly powerful before scp-001
ever got its hands on it this monster
had almost unparalleled reality warping
powers and was only kept contained in
site 100 by tricking it into believing
that the extensive rituals used to keep
it contained were actually effective
it's hard to say what specific form the
001 upgrade took on scp-2845
but we do know that shortly after it
happened site 100 was lost entirely and
it became impossible to contact any
personnel who were previously within and
this is just a handful of the countless
anomalies that were turned into
dangerous and terrifying super scps by
scp-001
leading what seemed like a coordinated
attack not just against the foundation
but humanity itself all foundation
resources were directed towards getting
this new scp-001 situation back under
control and that started to stretch the
already dwindling resources of the
besieged foundation even thinner why was
this happening who or what was the
mysterious scp-001
and what did it hope to achieve by
making earth's anomaly stronger to
answer these questions and have any hope
of stopping this process before it tore
the world asunder the scp foundation
would need to go to deeper and darker
places than they'd ever gone before and
reckon with the secrets of their past
present and future we'd love to tell you
that this is where the horrors end but
stay tuned because sadly this little
nightmare is only the beginning now go
check out
scp-001 which is the real zero zero one
and scp-001 oroboro cycle the full story
compilation for more of the endless
horrors and mysteries of scp-001